Wir wollen sprechen über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Das sind jetzt auch schon 28 Spieltage gespielt und es wird so langsam kribbelig. Aufstieg, Abstieg, all das wollen wir heute besprechen. Mit einer tollen Runde. Thorsten Wiese ist hier vom Gebrabbel Rot-Weiß-Podcast. Susanne Vetter ist hier von der Osnabrücker Zeitung und dem Podcast Brückengeflüster. Und Thomas Haufe ist hier vom Nurder FCM-Podcast. Was für eine geile Podcastrunde. Wir starten, ich freue mich. Und nun im Programm – der Rasenfunk.
Und das an Zunno. Markus Kort aus dem Gebühl. Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Mit jedem Spieltag wird es wahrscheinlicher, dass wir wieder solchextatische Torjubel hören, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Auch die 2. Liga, sie biegt auf die Zielgerade. Ein höchste Zeit für eine Ligatur und ich freue mich sehr, eine tolle Runde hier zu haben. Hallo Thorsten, schön, dass du mal wieder da bist.
Ich rede immer gerne über Fortuna, das weiß man ja.
Ja, wir haben schon das DFB-Pokal-Halbfinale schon so grob angesprochen, aber es gibt ja sehr viele Dinge im Positiven in deinem Leben. Ich freue mich schon, mit dir darüber gleich zu sprechen. Und ich freue mich, mit Susanne Vetter heute nochmal über den VfL Osnabrück zu sprechen. Hallo Susanne, schön, dass du da bist. Sehr gerne. Und das hat ja auch ganz perfekt geklappt mit diesem Überraschungssieg am Wochenende. Auch darüber werden wir gleich sprechen. Und dann ist endlich mal hier. Es war allerhöchste Zeit, dass wir jemanden vom Nur-der-FCM-Podcast hier haben. Thomas Haufe ist da. Thomas, wie schön, dass du endlich mal im Rasenfunk bist. Hi. Ja, damit habe ich auch schon die drei Vereine verraten, auf die wir heute unseren Schwerpunkt legen werden. Magdeburg, Fortuna Düsseldorf und natürlich der VfL Osnabrück. Aber zuerst beginnen wir – fast schon traditionell, kann man sagen – mit dem Blick auf die Lage der Liga. Da war so einiges los am Wochenende. Thorsten, du darfst mal beginnen. Was war denn für dich so die Geschichte jenseits der Fortuna, die man mitbekommen haben sollte, die du am interessantesten fandest?
Ja, durch das Pokal-Halbfinale gerade hatte ich natürlich auch ein bisschen einen Blick auf Kaiserslautern. Zumal wir ja auch vor einer Woche dort erst gespielt haben. Ich muss sagen, auch aus der Entfernung zumindest, ich mache mir ein bisschen Sorgen um den FCK. In Hamburg war ganz ordentlich mitgehalten, aber ähnlich wie gegen uns, wo sie 60 Minuten echt gut gespielt haben und uns sehr wenig Chancen gelassen haben, am Ende raus stehen sie ohne Punkte da und jetzt wirklich nicht zum ersten Mal. Und wenn jetzt Wunderheiler Friedhelm Funkel, den wir aus Düsseldorf ja auch noch kennen, schon die Hände aufgelegt hat und trotzdem die Verletzung noch nicht so richtig am Heilen ist, dann muss man sich glaube ich Sorgen machen.
Und das obwohl ja sogar Ragnar Ache getroffen hat. Das war ja das Take-Away von allen Sendungen, in denen Lautern vorkam in dieser Saison. Wenn Ragnar Ache spielt, dann ist alles halbwegs okay. Und wenn er nicht spielt, dann ist es so wie jetzt, Rang 17. Auf den ist Lautern abgerutscht. Also das sieht wirklich gerade nicht gut aus und auch die DFL macht sich schon so ihre Gedanken. Denn sollte Lautern in die Relegation kommen, dann wird das schwierig mit den Relegationsterminen rund ums DFB-Pokalfinale. Ich weiß nicht, Susanne, was so deine Geschichte des Wochenendes war, ob es auch der FCK war, ob du da einen Take zu hast. Ich meine, es ist natürlich aus Osnabrücker sich tatsächlich ganz interessant zu verfolgen, dass da jemand so richtig unten reinrutscht. Was sind für dich gerade so die wichtigen Themen?
Ja, also deswegen muss der DFB vielleicht auch gar nichts verlegen, weil vielleicht kommt er auch gar nicht in die Relegation. Ja, wir gucken da immer genau hin. Der VfL hat ja da auch erst gespielt für einiger Zeit, hat zwei zu drei verloren, weil Zima Kalla da damals getroffen hat, unter anderem der Ex-VfLer. Meine Überraschung war es trotzdem nicht. Ich schwanke natürlich zwischen zwei Sachen hin und her. Natürlich muss man immer gucken auf die Niederlage des FC St. Pauli in Karlsruhe. Das fand ich doch schon überraschend. Also das hatte ich fest im Tippspiel eingeplant, als drei Punkte oder zwei oder zumindest ein oder zwei für mich. Und überraschend, wenn man dann noch guckt, wäre eine faste Überraschung für mich der Auswärtssieg von Schalke gewesen. Denn da hatte ich noch nicht so viel davon, aber dann hat ja Hannover doch noch einen Ausgleich gemacht.
Also das war eine Abenturung auf faste. Ja, aber Schalke ist ja nochmal ein eigenes Thema für sich. Sie drängen sich auch wirklich in jeden Schwerpunkt hier irgendwie so ein bisschen rein. Aber Thorsten, wir hatten heute schon ein langes Vorgespräch, um es mal so zu sagen. Und damit ist auch schon kurz thematisiert. Das war schon sehr schalke, wie man sich dieses eigentlich gute Spiel dann selber kaputt gemacht hat. Wie ernst, würdest du sagen, ist da die Situation gerade auch aktuell angesichts der Punktgewinne von anderen Teams?
Ja, ich halte sie für sehr ernst, ähnlich ernst wie bei Kaiserslautern, mit vielleicht noch dem Damokless-Schwert der Finanzsituation mit Blick auf die dritte Liga im Hinterkopf. Schalke spielt wie eine Mannschaft, die im Abstiegskampf ist, die prinzipiell gut performt, eine gute Leistung zeigt, aber nicht mit den drei Punkten nach Hause geht, die sie zumindest, was ich in der Zusammenfassung gesehen habe gestern, durchaus verdient gehabt hätten in Hannover. Und das ist immer so dieses Zeichen, das kann mal zwischendurch, passiert das jedem Team, aber wenn das regelmäßig passiert und bei Schalke oder auch bei Kaiserslautern war es jetzt nicht das erste Mal, dann weiß man, dass die Lage ernst ist, denn die Qualität ist ja irgendwie da, aber diese Zusammenstellung dieser Mannschaft, und da wurde ja auch in der Ligatur schon sehr viel drüber gesprochen, die passt irgendwie nicht.
Gute Nachricht auf jeden Fall, dass jetzt der komplette Scouting starb von Ben Manga, offenbar gerade bei Schalke anheuert. Das weiß ich allerdings nur aus dem Rasenfunk-Forum, aber gäbe es eine bessere Quelle in diesem Internet. Mir fiele jetzt keine ein.
Ja, und ich kenne Raphael Tonello, weil er ehemaliger Fortuna-Stürmer aus der Bundesliga ist. 95, 96. Hat uns mal zu einem großen Auswärtssieg beim KFC Uerdingen geschossen zum 3 zu 1.
Das habe ich nur deshalb nicht gesagt, weil ich das als Grundwissen voraussetze. Ist ja klar. Ich sehe auch die anderen völlig gelangweilt nicken. Das war ja also Tonello damals bei Fortuna. Wer wüsste es nicht?
En Manga übrigens auch. Hat exakt ein großes Spiel im DFB-Pokal gegen den FC Bayern München gemacht. 1995.
Das wusste sogar ich. Siehst du mal. Irgendwie so Inselwissen. Man muss nur einen Job finden, wo sowas dann eine Rolle spielt. Also in dem Sinne fühle ich mich hier gerade als König der Runde. König sind aber auch zumindest an diesem Spieltag. Hansa Rostock gewinnt gegen Wien Wiesbaden. Sorgen damit dafür, dass Wiesbaden von da unten nicht wegkommt. Wiesbaden 31 Punkte. Braunschweig, wie gesagt, auf dem Relegationsplatz nur 30. Und Rostock springt ja eben hoch. Ist jetzt erstmals wieder seit einer ganzen Weile über dem Strich. Also ich vermute mal, Thomas, du wirst ja auch eher dich nach unten orientieren. Auch da habe ich schon gewisses Vorwissen aus unserem Vorgespräch. Das ist schon auf eine unangenehme Art und Weise für alle beteiligten Vereine eng geworden da unten.
Also das ist schon, wenn man das die letzten Wochen jetzt sieht. Ich meine, wer hätte gedacht, dass wir tatsächlich jetzt fünf Spiele hinlegen, in denen wir selber kein Tor schießen. Das ist schon ein ganz schönes Brett gerade. Und dieser Absturz, den wir da jetzt gerade punktetechnisch hinlegen, wenn man bedenkt, vor fünf Wochen waren es noch. Also nach dem Schalke-Spiel, nach dem 3-0 gegen Schalke, hat hier in Magdeburg gefühlt jeder gesagt, okay, das ist jetzt so die halbe Miete. Klassenerhalt ist dann, da hatten wir acht Punkte Vorsprung auf dem Relegationsplatz. Jetzt sind es noch zwei. Es wird eng da unten. Für mich die Überraschung tatsächlich ist zurzeit Osnabrück, dass die jetzt wieder auferstanden sind und dort eigentlich – ja, die waren ja schon tot. Das ist ja unglaublich, was sie da gerade abreißen. Klar sind immer noch sechs Punkte auf Braunschweig, aber es sind eben nur sechs Spiele. Ich weiß jetzt gerade beim FCM, weiß ich ja, dass Osnabrück auch noch gegen uns spielt. Das heißt, wenn man unsere Formen derzeit nimmt, können das für Osnabrück durchaus drei Punkte sein. Von daher schauen wir mal, was da noch möglich ist. Und ich hoffe natürlich, dass wir uns da doch noch mal verabschieden da unten.
Eine gewisse Skepsis, meine ich, aber bei Susanne gesehen zu haben gerade.
Ja, ich glaube, ein bisschen dauert es noch bis zur Auferstehung. Ostern war ja erst, also da ist der VfL noch ein bisschen weg. Aber zumindest sendet er Lebenszeichen und er sendet sie immer tüchtiger. Und ja, das muss man schon sagen, das gegen Fürth war auf viele Art und Weise jetzt auch ein Spiel, was noch mal Zuversicht geben kann.
Aber wirklich. Und sollte die Auferstehung gelingen, dann müsste sich natürlich der VfL in Osternbrück umbenennen. Und nicht mal Jesus hat so viele Lebenszeichen von sich gegeben vor der Auferstehung. Der war einfach weg, als sie kommen wollten, um sich um ihn zu kümmern. Aber das ist jetzt wiederum ein anderes Thema. Einen Info-Einschub wollte ich noch machen zu dem überraschenden Sieg vom KSC gegen den FC St. Pauli. Da darf man natürlich aber nicht vergessen, dass der KSC rückrunden Tabellen zweiter ist. Nur St. Pauli aktuell ist besser als der KSC. Hätte man sich das mal nicht in der Vorrunde versaut, weil es sind 7 Punkte Rückstand jetzt auf die Fortuna. Das heißt, wahrscheinlich wird der KSC nicht mehr eingreifen können. Aber im im Kontext der aktuellen Rückrunde dann gar nicht mehr so überraschend. Aber dann wollen wir mal reingehen in diese Liga. Und wir beginnen mit dem Team, das von euch dreien am weitesten umsteht. Das ist die Fortuna aus Düsseldorf. 49 Punkte hat man, Thorsten. Du grinst schon. Man hatte auch ein DFB-Pokal-Halbfinale und ich fand die Frage durchaus interessant, wie man das verdauen würde. Es war ein deutliches 0 zu viel gegen Leverkusen, ist jetzt auch schon anderen Teams passiert, aber natürlich war damit ein großer Traum geplatzt. Der zweite große Traum, nämlich – wahrscheinlich geht es ja doch um den Relegationsplatz, kannst du uns jetzt gerade sagen, ich weiß nicht, ob man irgendwie noch auf Rang 2 spekuliert – der bleibt am Leben durch ein 2 zu 0 gegen Braunschweig. Wie war die Reaktion der Fortuna auf das Ausscheiden im DFB-Pokal?
Daniel Tune sprach sogar von überragend, aber das machen Trainer glaube ich zwischendurch schon mal ganz gerne da ein bisschen mehr oben draufpacken. Das war eine berechtigte Frage, wie würde sich die Fortuna nach dieser Partie präsentieren? Würden die Köpfe hängelassen werden oder sonst was? Zumal mit Braunschweig, du hast eben die Rückrundentabelle angesprochen. Auch durchaus eine Mannschaft kam, die ich glaube im Moment Platz 9, Platz 8, Platz 7 – Platz 7 in der Rückrundentabelle. Ja, der Rückrundentabelle belegt. Das heißt also, ein Team, das sich aktuell in deutlich besserer Form befindet als noch in der Hinrunde. Das konnte man auch in der Partie sehen. Es war jetzt, sagen wir mal, nicht ein grandioser, absolut spektakulärer Sieg, sondern eher eine Reifeleistung. Das war vielleicht die wichtigste Erkenntnis aus dem Spiel, dass Fortuna lange, vor allem in der Hinrunde, ja nicht nur spektakulär kann, sondern mittlerweile auch kontrolliert und souverän und abgeklärt kann. Für meinen Geschmack ein paar Torschancen von Braunschweig zu viel. Da hat uns sicherlich die Tatsache geholfen, dass Braunschweig das torische Schießen vielleicht nicht unbedingt erfunden hat. Aber insgesamt, gerade in der zweiten Halbzeit, nachdem wir dann 2-0 in Führung waren, haben wir es doch schon sehr souverän und kontrolliert nach Hause gespielt. Man merkt jetzt auch, dass wir inzwischen wieder den fast vollständigen Kader zur Verfügung haben. Ein Problem, was gerade den rückrunden Start so ein bisschen holprig gestaltet hat.
Ja, mit Betonung aber auf ein bisschen. Also die Niederlage in der Liga kommt ja aus diesem Start in die Rückrunde. Anfang Februar hat man zuletzt verloren. Seitdem ungeschlagen und vor allem die letzten Partien, also 3-1 gegen Kaiserslautern, 4-0 gegen Osnabrück auswärts. Susanne hat es aus nächster Nähe erlebt, 2-0 zu Hause gegen den HSV. Also die Fortuna ist schon eins der stabilsten Teams aktuell in der Liga. Auch eines derjenigen Teams, bei denen die Kluft zwischen Hin- und Rückrunde gar nicht so groß auseinandergeht. Wir haben ja gerade ein paar positive Ausreißer besprochen, gibt aber auch negative Ausreißer, also Looking at 4 zum Beispiel, Rückrunde 17. Aktuell. Ist das vielleicht auch das größte Pfund jetzt in diesem engen Rennen um den Relegationsplatz? Man hat ja nur einen Punkt Vorsprung auf den HSV, aber immerhin schon fünf auf Hannover. Jetzt sind es dann eben sieben auf den KSC. Also es scheint ja fast ein Zweikampf zu werden mit dem HSV.
Wir sind zur richtigen Zeit auf jeden Fall in Form. Wir haben auch zur richtigen Zeit entsprechend wieder nahezu alle Spieler an Bord, was jetzt auch nicht unwichtig ist. Und wir haben es eben geschafft, aus dieser Schwächephase unsere Lehre zu ziehen. Da hat nämlich eine Weiterentwicklung stattgefunden. Und das ist etwas, was man auch vor allem dem Trainerteam durchaus positiv anrechnen kann, nämlich, dass man gerade nach diesen ersten Hinrundenspielen – ich habe es mir irgendwo aufgeschrieben, aber sehe es jetzt gerade nicht – ich glaube, nach den ersten sechs Spielen in diesem Kalenderjahr hatten wir elf Gegentore oder so etwas und jetzt haben wir in sechs Spielen nur noch drei Stück. Man sieht also, an der Defensive wurde was gemacht. Das hat Daniel Tune auch irgendwann mal auf so einer Spieltagspressekonferenz bestätigt. Und zwar ging es nicht darum, dass die Verteidiger irgendwie besser stehen müssen, sondern es ging um das gesamte mannschaftstaktische Defensivverhalten. Also auch gerade in der Offensive tatsächlich auch Spieler, die früher deutlich weniger an der Defensive beteiligt waren, sind inzwischen da, also haben da wirklich einen Sprung gemacht. Man würde jetzt den Namen wirklich in diesem Zusammenhang nicht erwarten, aber tatsächlich ist Christophs Tschollester ein sehr gutes Beispiel für bessere Defensivarbeit. Und da würden wir jetzt eigentlich über ganz andere Dinge sprechen, denke ich. Und da ernten wir das jetzt. Der Spielstil wurde eben auch so ein bisschen in einen kontrollierteren umgewandelt. Ich glaube, wirklich extremes Beispiel dafür war tatsächlich der Auswärtssieg beim VfL Osnabrück, wo wir – das ist jetzt vielleicht etwas also fast zynisch – aufgetreten sind, in dem wir gesagt haben, wir lassen jetzt Osnabrück mal spielen, denn wir glauben, dass wir das relativ gut kontrollieren können und schalten dann brandgefährlich um. Das heißt also, wir sind mit unter 40 Prozent Ballbesitz zu einem 4 zu 0 Auswärtssieg beim Tabellenletzten gekommen. Das spricht eine deutliche Sprache, also zum einen dafür, dass wir eben da dazugelernt haben, dass wir einfach nicht mit fliehenden Faden auf jeden Gegner draufgehen. Aber zum anderen zeigt es auch ein Charakteristikum von Daniel Thun, nämlich, dass er sehr stark versucht, sich am Gegner auszurichten. Vielleicht auch stärker als andere Gegner – das klappt nicht immer, siehe Bayer Leverkusen – aber, ja, wie gesagt, das haben auch schon andere probiert. Das wollen wir ihm jetzt auch nicht so sehr vorhalten. Mit einer krassen Defensivtaktik hätten wir halt 0-2 statt 0-4 verloren. Das ist im Pokal dann auch relativ egal. Das zeigt meiner Meinung nach die Reife der Mannschaft, aber eben auch, was da im Hintergrund durchs Trainerteam passiert ist. Das ist für mich ein ganz entscheidender Faktor für den aktuellen Erfolg.
Und Susanne, du hast, glaube ich, dieses Spiel ähnlich bewertet, wenn ich gerade dich nicken gesehen habe.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also was ich halt auch spannend fand, war natürlich, so hat es der VfL sogar erwartet, dass Fortuna eher ein bisschen abwartend spielt und auch den VfL ja mehr Ballbesitz geben lässt. Daraus hat der VfL übrigens dann auch gelernt jetzt hingegenführt. Aber was ich auch ganz spannend fand, war halt eben diese massive Effektivität. Also das hat man da gesehen, dass hier Fortuna wirklich sehr, sehr effektiv aktuell unterwegs ist. Und ja, in der Bremer Brücke ist man ja ziemlich nah dran. Und ich kenne ja Daniel Thun auch noch aus seinen Osnabrücker Zeiten, deswegen weiß ich auch, wie er nämlich pfeift. Und das hat man wirklich durch das ganze Stadion gehört. Und wenn man das mal beobachtet und vor allem dann auch hört, dann sieht man ganz genau, dass er darüber Signale gibt. Und ja, unter anderem eben auch Signale, wann diese Mannschaft wie ihr Pressing-Verhalten verändert. Und das fand ich ganz spannend, dass da wirklich, ja, ich glaube, die Fortuna nochmal in, was du es gerade gesagt hast, nochmal in den letzten Wochen sich da nochmal gesteigert hat und auch nochmal sich verändert hat in gewisser Weise. Also, dass es besser funktioniert.
Das mit dem Pfeifen wusste ich gar nicht. Das ist sehr spannend für mich. Ich war zwar beim Spiel, aber ich war hinter dem Tor, in Nähe Gäste-Block, sodass ich das nicht mitbekommen habe. Aber was du gesagt hast, dass wir, sagen wir mal so phasenweise, mal auf so ein starkes Pressing setzen und uns dann aber auch wieder sehr stark zurückziehen, ja, das ist sehr charakteristisch. Also, wir sind nicht so die Art Team, die immer vorne drauf geht und den Gegner ständig unter Druck setzt, sondern Tune verfolgt da ganz klar die Philosophie. Ballbesitz in ungefährlichen Räumen könnt ihr gerne haben, nur wenn ihr zu nah in den Strafraum kommt, dann wird es gefährlich, hat natürlich den Vorteil, dass die gesamte Abwehrreihe auch Räume hinter sich preisgibt, die dann Leute wie Jollis oder Felix Klaus oder andere dann natürlich auch zu nutzen wissen.
Und führt eben dazu, dass man aktuell in der Pole-Position um den Relegationsplatz ist. Also, du hast vorhin auf die Frage, ob man noch nach dem Rang-2-Shield nicht direkt geantwortet. Das habe ich als Antwort genommen. Sechs Punkte sind es auf Kiel, das ja auch einfach sehr stabil seine Runden zieht. Wir haben ja unter anderem in der letzten Ligatur besprochen, dass das noch die Hoffnung des Gastes war. Wenn wir jetzt aufs Restprogramm blicken, Thorsten, da haben wir WN Wiesbaden auswärts, Kreuter Fürth zu Hause, Schalke 04 auswärts, Nürnberg zu Hause, Kiel auswärts, aber schon am vorletzten Spieltag. Das heißt, sollte Kiel weiter so seine Kreise ziehen, dann sind die da durch. Ansonsten wird es nochmal ganz interessant. Dann reden wir uns auf jeden Fall nochmal. Ah, gut, weil du dann quasi den Sieg in Kiel mit einberechnest.
Das wäre dann das Finale. Also das ist aus meiner Sicht die spannende Konstellation. Ansonsten bin ich nicht unzufrieden mit dem Restprogramm. Bei allem Respekt vor anwesenden Vereinen. Aber die Heimspiele scheinen durchaus machbar. Ich glaube, jetzt auch vorletztes Rückrundenteam. An Nürnberg zuletzt auch nicht gerade am Overperformen. Und dann eben Magdeburg mit ihren eigenen Problemen, zu denen wir heute noch kommen. Dazu jetzt nächste Woche mit WN Wiesbaden, das schlechteste Rückrundenteam. Auswärts auf Schalke, da habe ich ein bisschen Respekt vor, weil Schalke zuletzt zu Hause immer stark war. Und natürlich ist es jetzt kein wirkliches Derby. Aber es ist natürlich ein volles Haus gegen ein Verein aus der Nähe. Da könnten noch ein paar Emotionen drin sein, die man nicht so gut kontrollieren kann. Aber insgesamt ist es jetzt nicht das absolut brandgefährliche Restprogramm, das wir da haben, meiner Meinung nach. Darum ja, ich schiele auf Platz zwei. Platz eins ist natürlich weg. Also trotz der Niederlage von St. Pauli, das werden sie machen. Und natürlich haben wir den HSV im Nacken, der sich ja auch ein bisschen zumindest stabilisiert hat, aber nicht so richtig überzeugend spielt. Genau, ich sehe auch schon deinen skeptischen Blick. Ich bin auch noch nicht so überzeugt, dass der HSV jetzt alles in Grund und Boden spielen wird, in den letzten Spielen, sodass ich mir da schon was ausrechne. Aber am wahrscheinlichsten ist vermutlich die Relegation. Und da könnte es natürlich auch eine pikante Konstellation geben.
Man muss sich sogar kurz überlegen, auf welche der pikanten Konstellationen du anspielst.
Also Köln eher als Bochum. Aber natürlich wäre auch Bochum nicht, sagen wir mal, ohne einen gewissen Charme. Und das wäre auch meine Wunschliste. Ich jinx das jetzt vielleicht, auch darum lasse ich das besser. Aber am liebsten Köln, vielleicht Bochum, Mainz, Siedlich, Qualitativ am höchsten.
Ja gut, aber Relegation ist noch mal das eigene Thema für sich. Gleichzeitig ist aber auch so was wie Restprogramm an den letzten Spieltagen ein eigenes Thema für sich. Also oft genug haben wir es erlebt, dass es ab einem gewissen Zeitpunkt der Saison gar nicht mehr so wirklich um den Tabellenplatz des Gegners geht, sondern um andere Faktoren. Hilf mir mal kurz, wie war denn die Fortuna in den letzten Jahren so drauf, wenn es noch um was ging? Kann man das besser als der HSV?
Also, letzte Saison haben wir das Feld da tendenziell eher von hinten aufgeräumt und wir haben es am letzten Spieltag dann sogar noch auf Platz 4 der Abschlusstabelle geschafft, waren vorher immer so 6. oder 7. Von daher würde ich schon sagen, ja, das können wir, haben wir auch am letzten Spieltag noch mal in Kaiserslautern gewonnen, wo man jetzt auch nicht einfach so gewinnt. Wir haben nicht so diesen großen, auch medialen Druck. Also natürlich ist Düsseldorf, also hat auch kein absolut leichtes Umfeld, aber es ist natürlich nicht diese Erwartungshaltung überall, die Fortuna muss jetzt aufsteigen und das muss jetzt unbedingt diese Saison geschafft werden. Klar, wie bei jedem Verein, der den Aufstieg nicht packt, wird es wahrscheinlich am Kader Änderungen geben, ob wir Spieler wie Jolis in der 2. Liga wirklich halten können. Sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Wenn er jetzt auch noch verteidigen kann, also das hätte er immer besser nicht beigebracht.
Genau, genau. Wollen wir über ihn reden oder sagen wir mal, lassen wir den Elefant im Raum so ein bisschen außen stehen. Aus meiner Sicht ist Jolis natürlich ein ganz entscheidender Faktor, vielleicht aktuell ligerweit der vom besten Spieler, den es gibt. Mit – schöne Statistik – mit Harry Kane in den ersten drei Profi-Ligen, der einzige Spieler, der im Kalenderjahr 2024 schon zweistellig getroffen hat. Die habe ich mal mitgebracht.
Ja, stark. Also und 18 Tore sind insgesamt sechs. Das heißt 24 Torbeteiligungen. Also jeder, der sich gefragt hat, warum hat die Fortuna eigentlich den besten Angriff der Liga?
Und Teil der Antwort ist auch, es sind interessanterweise nicht die Mittelstürmer. Vincent Vermeij in der Hinrunde neun Tore. Dieses Kalenderjahr noch kein einziges. Auch am Wochenende jetzt gegen Braunschweig eine sehr unglückliche Partie gemacht. Christoph Daferner von Nürnberg im Winter ausgeliehen, hat auch noch nicht getroffen. Und Marlon Mustapha, den wir ebenfalls ausgeliehen haben aus der zweiten italienischen Liga, aus der Serie B, mit immerhin zwei Treffern, einen auch in Osnabrück. Also, so kurios es klingt mit dem besten Angriff, aber es liegt aktuell nichts an den Mittelstürmern bei Fortuna, sondern einerseits an Jolles, aber auch daran, dass natürlich die gesamte Mannschaft – wir haben 17 verschiedene Torschützen schon diese Saison – dass die gesamte Mannschaft eine gewisse Torgefahr ausstrahlt. Felix Klaus sechs Tore, Aotan Naka sechs Tore, der übrigens aus meiner Sicht der zweite herausragende Spieler und Faktor aktuell ist, auch wenn er sich jetzt natürlich pünktlich vor dem Halbfinale einer Blinddarm-OP unterziehen musste, leider. Aber das dürfte jetzt vielleicht – also die nächste Woche dürfte er noch nicht zurückkommen, aber ich habe so die Hoffnung, vielleicht im nächsten Heimspiel. Und die sind aktuell also in einer wirklich geschlossen gut performenden Mannschaft, so die beiden noch mal herausragenden Akteure. Also Jolis, da muss man nur auf die Zahlen gucken, bei Tanaka, bei zentralen Mittelfeldspielern ist das meistens so ein bisschen versteckter, der einfach so der Dreh- und Angelpunkt, der Ruhepol unseres Spiels ist, der sowohl die Ballsicherheit hat und zumindest in der zweiten Liga kaum vom Ball zu trennen ist, der aber auch immer wieder gefährliche Schnittstellenpässe spielen kann, also auch nach vorne, hat jetzt zwar nur vier Torvorlagen, aber als eher defensiv orientierter Achter ist das sicherlich auch nicht so schlecht. Also ich denke da auch gerade übrigens an das Osnabrück-Spiel, wo Tanaka wirklich nahezu jeden zweiten Angriff mit einem genialen Pass eingeleitet hat. Das sind aktuell so auch die beiden bei uns so die Starspieler.
Meine Güte, man muss ja, also diese Euphorie, die ist absolut ansteckend, muss man sagen. Es scheint gerade wirklich gut zu laufen, aber wenn ich jetzt Susanne hier habe, und du hast ja vorhin schon angesprochen, Susanne, Danny Chun hat ja eine Osnabrücker Vergangenheit. Im Grunde könnte man sagen, dort hatte das Trainer da sein erst so richtig erlacht. Von der U17 über die U19 bis eben dann als Trainer hat er 100 Spiele für den VfL an der Seitenlinie gestanden. Dann kam die HSV-Station und dann wiederum ging es nach Düsseldorf. Wenn du jetzt blickst auf das, was man da bei der Fortuna sehen kann, welche Entwicklung siehst du dabei, Danny Chun?
Also natürlich eine große und vor allem eins mal vorneweg. Also ich würde ihm das, wie viele Osnabrücker hier, glaube ich, auch wirklich gönnen, vor allem auch am Ende der Saison vom HSV zu stehen. Und würde ihm, glaube ich, auch ganz gut schmecken. Aber ja, natürlich ist das nochmal eine Entwicklung. Er hat damals beim VfL, ist dann aus dem NLZ gekommen, hat dann als Interimstrainer bei Normen den Aufstieg geschafft, hat den VfL in der Klasse gehalten. Das waren richtige Stationen. Und dass er dann den Weg jetzt weitergegangen ist und mit der Fortuna den Verein trainiert, den er ja bis ins DFB-Pokal-Halbfinale geführt hat und eben jetzt auch wieder zu einem Aufstiegsaspiranten gemacht hat, das ist schon eine tolle Entwicklung, die er da genommen hat, muss man schon sagen. Und ja, trotzdem ist er jemand, der aber auch weiterhin – wie soll ich sagen – nahbar und bodenständig ist. Also zumindest wird das so wahrgenommen oder nehme ich hin, so wahr. Und das finde ich auch etwas, was wichtig ist, sich zu erhalten.
Was mir sehr sympathisch an ihm ist, natürlich im Gesamten auftreten und eben an dieser Normalheit, die er dir so ausstrahlt. Es ist ein wenig Affektiertes dabei. Er ist ein wirklich großer, fairer Sportsmann, was man nicht von jedem Trainer behaupten kann. Das finde ich sehr gut. Also das hört man häufig so in diesen Kommentaren auf den PKs hinterher. Auch so dieser Umfang ist dann nicht beleidigt in Leverkusen, sondern zollt dem Gegner da auch einfach viel Respekt. Oder hat ja sogar Christos Djolles für seinen Panenka-Elfmeter im DFB-Pokal in St. Pauli öffentlich gerügt, weil er das halt unsportlich fand. Ich finde das sehr sympathisch, denn das ist aus meiner Sicht hin und wieder durchaus eine Seltenheit heutzutage, dass Trainer das noch sehr stark ausstrahlen. Und jetzt kommt eben auch aus meiner Sicht wirklich diese qualitative Arbeit noch hinzu. Im Rasenfunk wurde ja immer schon länger nach dieser Frage geforscht, wofür steht dir in seinem Fußball? Ich habe eben auch versucht, noch mal ein bisschen Antwort zu geben. Also ich finde, das Charakterbild, das schärft sich so bei ihm. Intensität und Flexibilität, das sind die zwei Begriffe, die ich heute mitbringen wollte zu Daniel Thune. Das ist sein Fußball. Sieht man auch an den Laufwerten, Platz 2 in der Lauftabelle. Und die Flexibilität, die habe ich ja schon angesprochen.
Ich nenne noch ein Wort maximal.
Oh, absolut, absolut ist auch bei uns im Podcast inzwischen ein geflügeltes Wort, dass wir maximal unzufrieden sind oder maximal glücklich mit etwas. Ja, man merkt, ihr kennt ihn genauso.
Aber es ist so, ich glaube, für dieses Wort steht er auch. Und das ist etwas, was er nicht nur sehr gerne und sehr häufig sagt, sondern was er wirklich auch vorlebt. Und darüber hinaus glaube ich auch, dass er aus seiner Zeit beim HSV auch einiges mitgenommen hat, was die Arbeit, was so einen großen Club mit so einem großen Umfeld dann betrifft. Und das kommt jetzt der Fortuna zu Gute, hoffentlich.
Ja, so sieht es aktuell aus. Und wir werden es genau beobachten. Und das ist ja auch die perfekte Brücke zum 1. FC Magdeburg. Denn wir gehen vom einen ehemaligen HSV-Trainer, Daniel Thun, zum anderen ehemaligen HSV-Trainer, Christian Titz. Aber was müssen meine Augen sehen, lieber Thomas? Du hast es schon angesprochen. Christian Titz und seine Teams sind immer für viele Tore, für viel Spektakel bekannt. Und dann sehe ich mir die letzten Spieler an und ich sehe 0 zu 0, 0 zu 1, 0 zu 7, 0 zu 3. Und jetzt gegen Elvesberg schon wieder ein 0 zu 0. Es ist ja nicht zu glauben. Und wenn ich mal so bisherige Sendungen zum FCM zusammenfasse, dann muss ich Bares Artik die Schuld geben. Denn es wurde immer gesagt, Mensch, von dem sind wir so abhängig, der ist so gut. Ist es denn so einfach zu sagen, der ist nicht in Form oder er kommt nicht in die Szenen? Woran liegt es denn, dass Magdeburg – ausgerechnet Magdeburg – aktuell keine Tore schießt?
Das ist die 1-Million-Euro-Frage, glaube ich, zurzeit. Ich glaube, aus meiner Sicht ist das doch den einen oder anderen Grund mehr als nur Bares Artik. Also ja, man kann schon sagen, er ist nicht in der Form aus der Hinrunde, das muss man schon sagen. Liegt vielleicht auch daran, dass sich die Gegenspieler inzwischen auch auf sein Spiel so ein bisschen eingestellt haben. Liegt vielleicht auch daran, dass Chris Sentiz ihn jetzt auch in dem einen oder anderen Spiel eben nicht mehr über die linke Seite hat kommen lassen, sondern über die rechte Seite. Das ist vielleicht auch etwas, was seinem Spiel nicht so gut tut. Dann, weil eine seiner großen Stärken ist dann schon von der Außenbahn nach innen zu ziehen und dann eben entweder den Abschluss zu suchen oder eben den guten ersten Punt, diesen guten Ball zu spielen, die Initiative, den er eben auch spielen kann. Aber ich würde es jetzt, wie gesagt, nicht ungern nur an Bares Artik festmachen. Ja, es ist sicherlich ein Faktor, keine Frage, aber nicht der Faktor. Ich glaube, ein ganz großes Problem ist, dass wir vorne einfach zurzeit extrem harmlos sind. Also, wenn ich da an die Hinrunde denke, was wir da auch an Torfestivals teilweise hatten. Ich glaube, dieses Freak-Spiel gegen Hertha, dieses 6 zu 4, das war ja völlig geisteskrank, was da abging. Oder auch danach, dann spiele das auch vorher. Wenn man überlegt, das 3-0 gegen Schalke liegt ja auch nicht so lange zurück. Wie in der Hinrunde auch, ist Schalke offenbar so ein Bruchspiel für uns, ins Negative. Egal wie wir gegen Schalke spielen, es scheint irgendwie Einfluss auf unsere Leistung, die danach kommt, zu haben. Es ist wirklich frappierend, wie harmlos wir inzwischen nach vorne sind. Wir schaffen es kaum, uns Chancen zu erspielen. Wir hatten in den vier Spielen Paderborn, Nürnberg, Karlsruhe und Hannover in vier Spielen ganze zehn Torschüsse, also wirklich Bälle, die aufs Tor gingen. Das hatten wir dahin, glaube ich, teilweise pro Spiel. Das ist schon ein großer Faktor. Warum auch immer. Defensive Stabilität, die zu Beginn der Rückrunde durchaus da war. Futsch. Keine Ahnung, was heißt keine Ahnung. Es ist schon auch klar, wenn man überlegt, wir haben jetzt zwölf Gegentore inzwischen bekommen, nach eigenen Fehlern im Spielaufbau, also im eigenen ersten Drittel. Wenn du da natürlich die Bälle verlierst, beziehungsweise auch so spielst, dass du natürlich für den Gegner den Weg zum Tor noch verkürzt, dass er da mit zwei Kontakten auf einmal vor dem Tor steht und nicht noch von außen reinspielen muss oder sowas. Das ist dann schon extrem, und das war in Karlsruhe natürlich extrem auffällig, die sieben Gegentore. Das hätten auch zehn sein können, wenn man ehrlich ist. Hannover war auch völlig verdient. Jetzt hat man gegen Elbersberg zumindest hinten erstmal wieder die Null zu stehen, aber eben leider auch vorne, ja.
Ich meine, ich habe mir schon gedacht, dass die Antwort nicht so einfach ist und dass es sich auch nicht nur auf einen Spieler beschränkt. Jetzt ist aber ja natürlich die Gesamtentwicklung schon eine – das wäre jetzt nicht das erste Mal, dass man sieht, dass ein Team in so einen Negativstrudel hineingerät und es nicht mehr aus eigener Kraft da rausschafft. Als nächster Gegner kommt jetzt dann das Heimspiel gegen den HSV, kann man positiv wie negativ argumentieren. Einerseits starker Gegner, andererseits vielleicht endlich mal ein Spiel, wo eigentlich nichts erwartet wird und vielleicht kann man dann ja überzeugen. Aber was ist denn das für eine Dynamik, die der Magdeburg erfasst hat und wie groß sollten die Sorgen sein? Zwei Punkte Vorsprung sind es noch auf Braunschweig, auf dem Relegationsplatz.
Ja, es ist schon, also ich habe sehr große Angst, also Angst ist vielleicht das falsche Wort, sie reden immer noch von Fußball, aber es macht schon Sorgen gerade diese ganze Entwicklung, dass wir eben vorne überhaupt kaum noch Zugriffe haben, wirklich auf gute Torchancen, weil es die Gegner eben jetzt in den letzten Spielen auch schaffen, uns wirklich richtig zu ärgern. Elbersberg hatte wieder einen anderen Ansatz, wenn man aber die Gegneransätze von gerade von Karlsruhe und auf Hannover sieht, die uns dann doch sehr früh in erster Linie angepresst haben und uns dazu wirklich zu Fehlern gezwungen haben, dann ist das schon sehr, sehr auffällig. Und also die Entwicklung gerade, also Hamburg, wie du schon sagst, ja kann man vielleicht so sehen, naja da erwartet keiner was, aber ich glaube, wir sind jetzt in einer Phase, wo du dir solche Spiele nicht mehr leisten kannst. Wo du nicht sagen kannst, okay, ja ist nicht schlimm, wenn wir da jetzt nichts holen, ich glaube die Zeiten sind vorbei. Also wir haben zwei Punkte Forschung auf dem Regierungsplatz, das Spiel darauf ist dann in Rostock, das wird ein absolutes Sechs-Punktespiel, da kannst du dir eigentlich nicht erlauben, jetzt gegen Hamburg zu sagen, naja, es ist ein Bundesspiel, wenn wir da zwei nur verlieren, ist nicht so schlimm. Also das war in der Hinrunde vielleicht noch so, aber jetzt im jetzigen Zeitpunkt kannst du so nicht mehr in die Spiele gehen.
Woher das nur kommt, ich weiß es nicht. Aber da hast du ja schon den Blick vorausgeworfen und ich finde in diesen Sendungen so kurz vor dem Saisonfinale, da ist das auch fast das Interessantere, als eben zu erklären, Mensch, wie lief jetzt noch mal die Rückrunde, das ist jetzt viel, viel weniger wichtig, als eben das, was noch kommt. Und da kann man ja auch jetzt wieder positiv gedreht sagen, Magdeburg hat es absolut noch in der eigenen Hand. Man spielt gegen Rostock, aktuell Rang 15, man spielt gegen Osnabrück, aktuell Rang 18, man spielt gegen Kaiserslautern, aktuell Rang 17. Also drei Teams, die aktuell noch hinter Magdeburg stehen. Wie hat man sich denn in der Vergangenheit gegen solche Teams getan?
Na ja, wir hatten ja – da kann man ja jetzt gar nicht so weit zurückgucken – wir hatten ja in der Hinrunde auch die Situation, dass wir nach dem Schalke-Spiel auf einmal acht Spiele nicht gewonnen haben und dann kamen eben die Spiele gegen Osnabrück und Kaiserslautern zu unserem Glück zur richtigen Zeit, die haben wir beide gewonnen. Von daher war das dann, ich sage mal so ein bisschen so, da konnte man dann diese doch dann zu dem Zeitpunkt schwache Hinrunde dann noch noch drehen. Da hast du dann am Ende 20 Punkte gehabt und noch Hinrunde. Das war völlig in Ordnung. Letztes Jahr war es auch in der Rückrunde so, dass wir zum Ende hin die Spiele dann auch gezogen haben. Das ist so ein bisschen das, was mir auch Hoffnung macht. Und eben wie du schon gesagt hast, diese drei Spiele gegen direkte Konkurrenz, wobei man natürlich sagen muss, zwei Spiele davon auswärts, in Kasserslautern haben wir uns die letzten Jahre schon schwergetan. In Kasserslautern haben wir, glaube ich, auch noch nicht gewonnen, seitdem wir gegen Kasserslautern mal gespielt haben. Von daher weiß man da auch, was einen da erwartet. Und deswegen tue ich mich auch schwer zu sagen, okay, verlassen wir uns auf diese Spiele. Also wir sollten schon gegen Hamburg, gegen Fürth, Düsseldorf ist für mich am letzten Spiel, da werden wir nichts holen, glaube ich.
Also Fürth und Hamburg sind schon Spiele, hast du den Blick gerade von Torsten gesehen? Torsten hat gerade schon gesagt, im Moment waren wir ja schon drei Tage auf Mallorca, also die Spiele, und dann wird das so ein Skandalspiel. Hatten wir das nicht in der letzten Woche?
Und wenn das so ist, wenn der Zweite Mal das aufläuft, dann ist das auch okay. Nein, aber ich...
Max, das gab es tatsächlich noch mal. In Magdeburg wird noch gespielt, sage ich nur. St. Pauli damals auf Mallorca, im Magdeburg.
Das war einer meiner schwerzigeren Momente, bitte nicht.
Ja, und gab es das nicht auch bei Darmstadt? War das nicht auch die Geschichte, dass die noch mal drei Tage feiern waren und dann die Meisterschaft am letzten Spieltag verspielt haben? Darauf hatte ich... Scheint so ein Zweitliga-Ding zu sein. Weiß ich jetzt auch nicht. Nein, nein, nein.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, ich glaube schon, dass wir vorher die Punkte haben sollten. Also im letzten Spieltag möchte ich nicht, dass es in Düsseldorf noch um irgendwas geht. Für uns, für Düsseldorf ist mir das egal. Für uns möchte ich nicht, dass da noch um was geht. Also da sollten wir vorher auf jeden Fall Fürth oder Hamburg irgendwie noch zwei bis vier Punkte geholt haben.
Und wie ist aktuell die Stimmung im Umfeld bei Magdeburg? Weil es ist ja ein besonderer Standort, aber auch dahingehend besonders, dass das bisher nicht immer alle Mechanismen gegriffen haben, zumindest in jüngerer Vergangenheit. Also bei anderen Teams, da wäre der Trainer schon so stark in der Kritik, dass er vielleicht gar nicht mehr im Amt wäre. Wie ist denn das jetzt mit Christian Titz und aktuell?
Naja, im Umfeld ist es schon, also fan-technisch ist es schon relativ unruhig inzwischen. Im Verein sieht es so aus, als ob noch Ruhe herrscht. Wobei natürlich auch da, klar muss man sagen, fünf Spiele nicht gewonnen, kein Tor geschossen. Ich denke mal schon, dass das auch im Verein zumindest für Diskussionen sorgt. Im Umfeld wird es langsam haarig. Es gibt nicht wenige, die sagen, das Spiel ist durchschaut. Wir sollten jetzt wirklich gucken, es ist kein Plan B erkennbar in den Spielen. Der Vorwurf, der stimmt in meiner Meinung tatsächlich. Also wenn Plan A nicht funktioniert, wird Plan A weiter versucht. Du kannst, auch wenn du dann viel hinten liegst, du spielst trotzdem genauso weiter und kriegst noch drei, wie in Karlsruhe. Das ist die Kritik, die sich gerade festmacht. Das nächste ist natürlich dann auch, dass es der Tatsache geschuldet ist, dass man im Winter, finde ich, den Fehler gemacht hat oder auch im Sommer schon, dass man sich zu sehr auf die zwei Stürmer, die man im Kader hat, verlassen hat, auf Lukas Schuhle und Lukas Tainos. Da ist einfach zu wenig gemacht worden, vor allem im Sommer, finde ich. Man hat keine Brücke nach Saarbrücken ziehen lassen. Da kann man nicht sagen, wie man will, das ist okay, aber man hätte in meinen Augen da noch nachrüsten sollen. Lukas Tainos, das weiß man aufgrund der Verletzungshistorie, gibt keine 34 Spiele pro Saison. Lukas Schuhle ist in meinen Augen auch noch nicht so weit, ein Zweitliga-Stürmer zu sein, der dir 10, 12, 15 Tore garantiert. So einen Stürmer brauchst du, wenn du da unten stehst, brauchst du einfach jemanden, der dir zumindest zweistellige Torzahlen garantiert, um drin zu bleiben. Und das ist, glaube ich, unser ganz großes Problem zurzeit. Und das muss man irgendwie lösen. Die Frage ist, wie kann man Torgefahr entwickeln?
Wir hatten ja im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen gequatscht vor der Aufnahme heute, Thomas. Und da hatte ich auch gesagt, weil wir ja schon zweimal gegeneinander gespielt haben durch das DFB-Pokalfürttelfinale, dass ihr so ein bisschen in Schönheit sterbt. Das war so mein Eindruck. Also ihr habt uns da zeitweise auch eine ganze Halbzeit komplett eingeschnürt. Aber dann wart ihr halt im Pokal zum Beispiel nur 1-0 vorne und wir konnten es dann hinten raus einfach noch mal drehen und im Liga-Spiel sogar mit 2-0. Also einerseits so – ich wollte nicht daran erinnern – also ihr hattet Torschancen da, ihr hättet auch vier schießen können in diesen guten Phasen. Aber ihr wart dann hinten immer anfällig und ich habe das Gefühl, zumindest so von außen, der 1. FC Magdeburg ist so eine Mannschaft, die sehr anfällig ist für Fehler in der letzten Reihe, also so diese Ausnahmefehler, die auch so unforced passieren oder so was, dass man Verteidiger mal so ein Ball verdribbelt oder so. Also ich finde, das mag dem Spielstil geschuldet sein, aber irgendwie, finde ich, passiert das bei euch auffällig häufig. Oder irre ich mich da, ist das einfach zu weit weg?
Also ich bin der Meinung, dass es schon auch natürlich ein Stück weit am Spielstil liegt. Also wenn jetzt ein Spieler fünf oder sechs Mal den gleichen Fehler macht, dann kann es am Spieler liegen. Wenn aber fünf, sechs Spieler diese Fehler machen, dann liegt es nicht am Spieler. Also dann liegt es meiner Meinung nach schon auch darin begründet, dass eben genau so gespielt wird. Und Christian Thies hat das ja nach dem Hannover-Spiel auch wieder gesagt. Er hat gesagt, wir wollen hinten raus spielen, wir wollen den Ball nicht schlagen, wir wollen immer Kontrolle haben. Ja, die Frage ist dann, ist das immer so sinnvoll? Und ich fand da schon, dass man in Elbersberg in der Beziehung schon einen Schritt gemacht hat. Also ich finde, man hat da auch öfter mal den Ball hinten rausgeschlagen, wenn es dann auch mal nicht mehr möglich war, dass man den Ball zum nächsten möglichen Spieler drei Meter von sich wegspielen kann oder so. Schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt tatsächlich ein Trend ist oder ob das jetzt nur gegen Elbersberg so eine Alltagsfliege war. Weil dieses Entschönert-Sterben, das ist genau der Punkt. Also man versucht da technisch ansehnlich Fußball zu spielen und man hört ja auch immer mal wieder, wobei ich mir inzwischen da als Fan auch ein bisschen veralbert von den gegnerischen Trainern vorkomme, wenn Christian Eicher nach einem 7-0 seiner Mannschaft sagt, wir wissen ja, was Maxur von tollen Fußball spielen kann. Ich denke mir so, Leute, ihr habt uns gerade 7-0 zerfetzt. Also was redet ihr denn hier bitte von schönem Fußball? Und die Frage ist immer, was ist schön auf Fußball? Also 0 zu 11 Tore in fünf Spielen, jetzt kann man darüber diskutieren, ob das schön auf Fußball ist. Für mich ist das katastrophal. Und ja, wenn man eben – und ich glaube tatsächlich, da auch ein ganz großes Problem, was im Gegensatz zu anderen Mannschaften und im Abstiegskampf ist unsere klatante Schwäche bei Standard-Situationen, gerade im Offensivbereich, also wir schaffen es nicht im Offensivbereich, Torchancen nach Standard-Situationen zu kreieren. Es ist unglaublich. Wir haben Eckbälle, da haben wir drei Ballkontakte, da ist der Ball beim eigenen Torwart. Also das ist – und das sind alles Dinge. Und das merkt sich jetzt, das kommt jetzt alles zusammen in einer Phase, wo du es überhaupt nicht gebrauchen kannst. Also wenn du das am Anfang der Saison hast, ja, dann sagst du, gut mein Gott, aber jetzt kommt das in einer Phase, wo du es gar nicht gebrauchen kannst. Du brichst es komplett ein, hast einen super Vorsprung verspielt, den du nach 24 Spielen hattest, wo jeder gesagt hat, cool, wir können möglicherweise für die kommende zweite Saison planen und brichst es so ein. Und jetzt müssen, glaube ich, es ist viel beschworen, ich glaube man kann es inzwischen auch nicht mehr hören, aber jetzt müssen auch mal andere Tugenden auf den Rasen als immer nur versuchen, Hackspitze eins, zwei, drei schön rausspielen hinten, sondern da muss jetzt auch einfach mal andere Sachen an der ersten Stelle stehen und da zählt für mich erstmal grundsätzlich Leidenschaft dazu und dass man Bock hat, dem Gegner auch weh zu tun und eben nicht in Schöna zu sterben.
Und kann das der Kader auch?
Ja, das ist genau die Frage, die sich hier auch jeder stellt. Wenn man die letzten fünf Spiele als Maßstab hernimmt, nein, muss man so ehrlich sagen. Ich fand gegen Karlsruhe schlimm, dass man nach einem 0-4-Zer Halbzeit rauskommt und sich innerhalb von fünf Minuten wieder zwei rein kleint lässt, dass man sich dann auch so in sein Schicksal ergibt. Also Karlsruhe hätte ja dann, ich bin dem eigentlich nur so dankbar, dass der dann seine guten Stürme alle runtergenommen hat und dann da eben Spieler, die eben noch nicht so gut sind, die dann diese Chancen nicht gönnen zu haben, weil sonst wären es wirklich zehn Stück da über. Und auch gegen Hannover, genau das Gleiche. Man fängt dann an, man hört zwei Wochen lang bei der Länderspiel-Verpause, man hört zwei Wochen lang, ja, wir haben anders alarmisiert, wir wissen, wo die Schwächen sind, wir werden das jetzt ändern, dann geht das Spiel gegen Hannover los und du spielst zehn Minuten die gleiche Krütze wie gegen Karlsruhe und wunderst dich dann am Ende. Ich meine, ich denke mal, vielleicht habt ihr es gesehen, das ist das Interview von Luca Schuhler bei Sky, wo dann Leuten, die hier seit 30 Jahren zum Fußball gehen, empfiehlt, sich in neue Stadion zu suchen, weil sie nach zehn Minuten es gewagt haben zu pfeifen. Dann frage ich mich halt auch schon, wie da die Selbstvernehmung bei den Spielern ist in so einer Situation. Du verlierst innerhalb von zwei Wochen, kriegst 0 zu 10 Tore, verlierst zwei Spiele und gibt dann so eine Aussage, wo ich mir dann denke, also bei einem Publikum, was ja wirklich sehr, sehr ruhig ist. Also wenn ich mir überlege, was teilweise schon in Rostock abgegangen ist, was in Kassel-Lautern schon abgegangen ist oder auch an anderen Standorten, da ist es ja bei uns wirklich ruhig. Also es gibt keine, es gab noch keine Laufmeilen für Spieler ums Stadion drumrum oder sowas. Also von daher, hier ist es ja ruhig. Und wenn man dann mal nach zehn Minuten einen Unmutkund tut und dann trifft ein Spieler so eine Aussage, dann frag ich mich da auch schon, wie sieht es da bei den Spielern auch mit der Selbstreflektion in den jetzigen Leistungsphasen geradeaus? Deswegen ist die Frage, ob der Kader das hergibt, absolut berechtigt.
Ja, beziehungsweise, natürlich kann man das als mangelnde Selbstreflektion sehen. Es ist definitiv keine schlaue Aussage im Kontext gewesen. Vielleicht spricht da aber auch nur dieselbe Hilflosigkeit und derselbe Frust raus, den man ja jetzt auch bei dir gerade raus hört. Also, wir jetzt nicht allzu Fußballromantisch formulieren, aber die Spieler sitzen ja schon in einem ähnlichen Boot wie die Zuschauer. Niemand ist gerade zufrieden. Der Kontrast ist jetzt besonders stark, weil, als wir uns das letzte Mal gesehen haben, das war im Oktober, glaube ich. Da war nicht alles Rosenrot, aber du warst auf jeden Fall besser drauf. Das kann ich verbrieft hier auf Band sagen. Man kann es ja im Podcast auch nachhören. Also, ich erkläre jetzt ja hier keine Geheimnisse. Woher soll der Impuls kommen? Jetzt, wenn du so über Christian Titz und Plan A und den fehlenden Plan B gesprochen hast, da hat sich der Frust für mich schon so angehört, als ob du dir da fast sogar noch eine Veränderung wünschen würdest auf der Trainerposition. Hab ich das richtig rausgehört?
Nie ein. Also, ich sage mal, wenn du jetzt noch zwei Spiele verlierst, ich glaube, wenn du jetzt gegen Hamburg verlierst und dann in Rostock, ich glaube, dann ist es in meinen Augen alternativlos. Dann musst du was tun. Wenn du die Klasse halten willst oder du sagst, ganz klar, das würde ich mir vom Verein ein Stück weit auch wünschen, oder du sagst, ganz klar, wir gehen auch in die dritte Liga mit Christian Titz. Wenn da eine klare Aussage dazu kommt, ich glaube, da sind hier in Magdeburg viele Leute fein mit, wenn dann so eine Aussage kommen würde und wenn man allerdings sagt, wir wollen die zweite Liga halten und du verlierst die nächsten zwei Spiele, was ich jetzt natürlich überhaupt nicht hoffe, dann sollte man sich, glaube ich, schon Gedanken machen, ob nicht da vielleicht nochmal ein Impuls der Richtige wäre. Die Frage ist natürlich, ob das nach, ich glaube, dann 30 Spielen, ob das überhaupt noch was bringt. Weil der Kader ist ja, das muss man schon sagen, der Kader ist schon sehr auf Christian Titz und seinen Fußball zugeschnitten. Das muss man schon sagen, eher kleine Spieler, dribbelstarke Spieler, die eben weniger über das körperliche kommen. Das sieht man ja auch in unserem Spiel, dass wir da große Probleme mit Gegnern haben, die dann eine gewisse Körperlichkeit ins Spiel bringen. Also von daher ist da die Frage, ob ein Trainerwechsel wirklich das bringen würde, was man sich vorstellt. Weil man muss, was man sagen muss, den Eindruck kann man schon gewinnen, dass Mannschaft und Trainer, dass das noch passt. Also dieses Binn-Verhältnis ist, das passt noch. Und ich glaube, da macht es keinen Sinn, den Trainer zu tauschen, wenn das Binn-Verhältnis noch in Ordnung ist. Weil das ist so eine Situation, die hat man hier von ein paar Jahren schon mal, das ist völlig in der Hose gegangen. Also von daher wäre ich da auch vorsichtig zu sagen, okay, da muss jetzt unbedingt ein Trainerwechsel her. Weil ich eben den Eindruck habe, dass dieses Verhältnis absolut noch intakt ist.
Hilf mir kurz, wann war das, dass man Trainer gewechselt hat, obwohl das Binn-Verhältnis gut war?
Das war damals in der dritten Liga, als man von Stefan Kremer auf Klaus-Titer Wollitz gewechselt ist. Was ein riesengroßer Fehler damals war und uns in absoluter Abstiegsnüte gebracht hat am Ende. Wir kennen uns da aus, hier in Magdeburg, mit völlig unnötigen Trainerwechseln und da wäre ich jetzt erstmal auch noch eher defensiv mit.
Wer würde so eine Ansage machen im Verein, dass man eben sagt, mit Christian Thiers auch in die dritte Liga, wofür man ja auch gute Argumente haben könnte? Er hat ja auch Magdeburg hochgeführt und so weiter und so fort. Wer wäre da die Stimme, die Autorität im Verein, die das machen könnte? Müssen wir da auf die sportliche Führung gucken? Aus welcher Richtung käme das?
Kann eigentlich in meinen Augen nur Othmar Schorck als sportlicher Leiter sein, der dann diese Ansage machen würde, könnte, sollte.
Und wie äußert er sich von dem anderen?
Zur Zeit ist Ruhe. Letzte Woche Mittwoch war eigentlich eine Medienrunde anbraunt, die wurde kurzfristig abgesagt. Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, in die eine Richtung ein schlechtes Zeichen, in die andere Richtung ein gutes Zeichen. Man bleibt weiterhin ruhig. Das wird man sehen. Ich denke, nach dem HSV-Spiel, wenn man da nicht dreifach Punkte bzw. verliert, dann wird es auch von Othmar Schorck, denke ich, eine Ansage geben. In welche Richtung auch immer.
Das ist echt eine verfahrende Situation in Magdeburg. Das ist jetzt nichts Neues, wenn man so ein bisschen auf die Ergebnisse der letzten Wochen geblickt hat. Aber es wird nicht so arg viel besser, wenn man jetzt genauer hinblickt, so wie wir es gerade gemacht haben. Ehrlicherweise. Ich habe Susanne fast schon mental Notizen machen sehen. Wo könnte Osnabrück vielleicht noch ansetzen? Und ich meine, ihr beide, ihr fiebert ja auf das Spiel hin. In drei Spieltagen ist es so weit. Am 31. Spieltag. Osnabrück in Magdeburg. Da fährt Thomas jetzt schon rein. Ich vermute einfach, Susanne, dass du ein bisschen entspannter sein kannst. Denn von Osnabrück haben viele gar nicht mehr so viel erwartet. Vielleicht sogar auch Osnabrück selbst. Das wäre jetzt die erste Frage, die ich dir stellen wollen würde. Wie ist die Stimmung da gerade? Man ist ja immer noch Tabellen-18er, aber ein besser Gelaunter vielleicht?
Deutlich besser Gelaunter. Ja, also ich muss wirklich sagen, es ist nach der Hinrunde, die im weiten Teilen des Astris verlaufen ist, hier in Osnabrück hat so ein kleines, winzig kleines Flämmchen Hoffnung, flackert gerade wieder so. Die letzten Spiele, jetzt zwei Siegeln, Folge davor gegen HSV gut gespielt, Spiel gegen Hannover, die zwei Siege auch nochmal, da ist jetzt schon einiges an Stabilität gekommen in der Rückrunde und das ist auch meiner Meinung nach ganz klar auf den Trainerwechsel zurückzuführen. Uwe Koshinat hat die Mannschaft stabilisiert. Wir haben es heute mal ausgerechnet für einen Artikel in den nächsten Tagen. In der Koshinat-Tabelle steht der VfL auf Rang 11. Wenn man jetzt die Spiele in der Hinrunde noch rausrechnet, also nur die Rückenrunde nimmt, ist der VfL neunter. Also da ist der Kurs auf Klassenerhalt. Das ist schon eine gute Leistung, die auch vielen hier in Osnabrück wieder Hoffnung gibt. Thorsten, du hast ja vorhin erzählt, dass du mit der Fortuna hier im Stadion warst. Und wenn man das sieht, dass selbst nach 0 zu 4 gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf das Stadion kurz vor Schluss einmal aufgestanden ist, waren fast alle im ausverkauften Heimbereich und haben gesungen, wir sind die Osnabrücker, wir sind immer da. Ich weiß nicht, was dir da durch den Kopf gegangen ist, aber ich habe mit ein paar Fortuna-Fans auch hinterher gesprochen. Die waren durchaus auch beeindruckt davon, muss man sagen.
Also ich fand definitiv, es herrschte eine sehr gute, positive Energie, obwohl das Spiel sich so ein bisschen sportlich angefühlt hat wie, das war es jetzt, das war so die letzte Chance, die vergeben wurde. Aber diesen Schulterschluss hatte man bemerkt. Irgendetwas hattet ihr gefeiert zur Halbzeit. Da gab es auch Feuerwerk und so was. Ich weiß aber nicht mehr, was das genau war. Also die Leute hatten irgendwie das Gefühl, das hier ist nicht vorbei. Auch wenn es sportlich sich so anfühlte. Aber es geht noch weiter und das ist vielleicht jetzt genau die Folge daraus. Also ja, das habe ich auch ein bisschen wahrgenommen. Also vor allem diese positive Energie, das eben nicht – also ich stand fairerweise, muss ich das sagen, im Heimbereich. Das heißt, ich habe auch hier und da so ein paar Heimstimmen wahrgenommen. Die waren natürlich die typischen Kritiker, die auch immer, das wird nichts mehr mit denen und so was. Das hat man natürlich auch gehört, aber insgesamt, ja, also fand ich es auch bemerkenswert. Also da war, sagen wir mal, keine Wut, keine Aggression oder so dabei, so dass man so auf die Mannschaft wütend sei und so. Vielleicht aber auch, wenn man von vorne rein so eine realistische Einschätzung hatte, dass es halt einfach auch nicht einfach werden würde, den Klassenerhalt zu schaffen.
Ja, also natürlich, das ist auch klar. Auch gegen Fortuna sind dann einige vorher gegangen. Es gab auch ein paar Piffel. Das stimmt schon, aber es ist nicht so diese angespannte Atmosphäre, sondern im Moment ist es, glaube ich, eher dieser Schulterschluss, den du beschreibst, zwischen Mannschaft und Verein, wo der ja damals unter anderem auch zwischen den Fans und dem Verein und der Mannschaft wieder unter Daniel Tune wiederbelebt worden ist mit, also nochmal, oder nochmal so einen Kick bekommen hat. Und ich glaube wirklich, dass das im Moment auch entscheidend sein kann, diese Atmosphäre, dass dieses Fünktchen Hoffnung vielleicht noch ein bisschen schimmert.
Ich fand es auf jeden Fall schön, mal wieder in der Bremer Brücke gewesen zu sein nach langer Zeit. Und der Unterschied zu so einem Stadion wie in Leverkusen, der könnte einfach nicht größer sein. Und ich bin ganz ehrlich, da schlägt auch der Romantiker in mir ein bisschen höher, wenn ich eher in Osnabrück sein darf, als halt in der Bayer Arena.
Susanne, ich habe mal noch eine Frage dazu. Es gab ja bei euch Ende November oder Mitte November einen Trainerwechsel von Tobias Schweinsteiger hin zu Uwe Koshinat. Was hat sich denn jetzt konkret unter Uwe Koshinat verändert im Vergleich zur Zeit von Tobias Schweinsteiger? Das ist die erste Frage und die zweite Frage. Es lief ja auch anfangs unter Koshinat nicht wirklich. Ist ja jetzt so ein Trend da, hat er was verändert? Ist einfach anderes, vielleicht auch Spieler zurückgekommen, die verletzt waren? Woran liegt das auf einmal, dass dieser Glaube auch wieder da ist, scheinbar in Osnabrück?
Also ganz richtig ist es nicht, weil das erste Spiel unter Koshinat ist 0 zu 4 verloren gegangen auf Schalke, das stimmt. Aber da hat er wirklich nur wenig Zeit gehabt. Und dann war es schon St. Pauli und Hertha mit den beiden Unentschieden noch unter ihm. Also er hat quasi zwei Unentschieden dann in den ersten drei Spielen geholt. Und danach sind sie dann ins Trainingslager gegangen, nach Spanien, nach Oliva. Da war ich mit einem Kollegen, waren wir dann zu zweit im Trainingslager in Spanien mit dabei und haben da ziemlich genau gesehen. Ja, das Koshinat eben versucht, bestimmte Dinge zu verändern, die vor allem auch die Stabilität in der Abwehr betreffen. Also, was man ganz deutlich sagen muss, ist, dass der VfL in der Abwehr viel, viel stabiler geworden ist. Ich habe es vorhin mal geguckt, also sie haben jetzt unter Koshinat 20 Gegentore kassiert, aber wenn man da das 04 Schalke und 04 Düsseldorf rausrechnet, dann ist das schon eine stabile Leistung. Und da hat er es einfach geschafft, die Mannschaft zu aufzustellen, dass sie viel stabiler agiert, wo es beim VfL eher noch ein Problem ist. Aber das habe ich jetzt gehört, ist ja bei euch auch nicht gerade viel anders, es ist in der Offensive häufiger. Da hat man jetzt ein bisschen länger nach einer Strategie gesucht, offensiv auch bestimmte Ideen zu entwickeln, kreativ zu sein, auch unter anderem gegen Mannschaften, Thorsten hat es vorhin gesagt, wurden die dem VfL dann eher mal den Ball überlassen. Und auch da hat sich in den letzten Wochen gezeigt, dass der VfL sich auch hier verbessert hat. Unter anderem jetzt Christian Conté, der lange Zeit ein bisschen unglücklich war über seine Torausbeute, jetzt unter anderem zweimal hintereinander getroffen. Erich Engelhardt ist der Stabilste, der ist jetzt auch schon zweistellig in seiner ersten Zweitliga-Saison als Stürmer. Also ja, auch da hat Kozienad was bewirkt. Und das sind jetzt vielleicht die beiden wichtigsten Punkte auf deine Frage.
So ein bisschen der Anti-Magdeburg-Weg. Also man ist jetzt defensiv stabiler geworden. Und irgendwie schießt man aber jetzt vorne auch Tore. Und so hat man ja 15 von 24 Punkten in der Rückrunde jetzt geholt. Und vor allem jetzt eben die beiden Siege in Folge gegen WN Wiesbaden. Da konnte man vielleicht noch ein bisschen drauf spekulieren, dass man es vielleicht schafft, beim Mitaufsteiger noch was zu holen.
Da muss ich ganz entscheidend mit dem Kopf schütteln. Ich war so, so häufig in WN Wiesbaden, Thorsten, wenn wir über hässliche Stadien sprechen. Also in diesem Schmuckkästchen, wie wir es immer nennen. Ich war da so häufig mit dem VfL Osnabrück, in der VfL Osnabrück hat nie was gerissen. Selbst in der vorletzten Ausstiegssaison, in der Saison unter Daniel Tune, als wir wirklich sehr, sehr häufig gewonnen haben, hat der VfL in Wiesbaden noch verloren. Kurz vor der Mallorca-Fahrt übrigens und nicht danach. Also ich glaube, ich habe mit Pippo Kühn, der jetzt seit 5, 5 Jahren, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere und richtig rechnen kann, beim VfL ist, und mit Baschki Maidini, der ja schon mal beim VfL lange gespielt hat und jetzt dann wieder zurückgekommen ist, mit beiden gesprochen nach dem Spiel in Wiesbaden. Und die haben gesagt, wir haben gefühlt hier eigentlich immer nur eine auf den Deckel bekommen, und zwar teilweise auch richtig heftig. Boah, hat es gut getan, hier endlich mal zu gewinnen.
Ich war noch nie bei Wien-Wiesbaden, nächste Woche ist das erste Mal. Und damit kompletiere ich nämlich auch meine zweite Liga dann in der aktuellen Konstellation. Ich bin gespannt, aber ich kenne es natürlich so von diesen Drittliga-Berichten, da hat das Stadion jetzt nie, sagen wir mal, ein Zauber irgendwie ausgestrahlt. Aber ich will jetzt auch hier nicht über die zahlreichen Wien-Wiesbaden-Fans lästern, ihr Stadion.
Eben, gegen Osnabrück waren es immerhin 6000, die da im Stadion waren. Da muss man auch erstmal bestimmen. Ja, okay, also wir haben jetzt alle noch mal Salz genommen und in die Bunden verteilt. Okay, also ich gestehe ein, gegen Wien-Wiesbaden konnte jeder, der es besser wusste als ich, auch nicht spekulieren. Und jetzt aber Kräuter Fürth, 2 zu 0 besiegt am Wochenende. Wir sind da vorhin so ein bisschen nonchalant drüber hinweggegangen, aber damit hat man im Grunde sämtliche Hoffnung in Fürth auf irgendwas in dieser Saison begraben. Wie war denn das möglich? Was war das für ein Spiel?
Also es war nicht unbedingt ein hübsches Spiel, vor allem am Anfang. Das hat Koshinat sogar noch hässlicher vorausgesagt und es ist vielleicht so, dass auch ein Gegenstück zu Magdeburg – Koshinat sagt halt häufig auch voraus oder vor den Spielen, Leute, das wird vielleicht nicht unbedingt hübsch, das kann auch ein hässliches Spiel werden, aber er hat angekündigt, wir müssen Fürth niederringen. Also er wollte unbedingt diesen Kampf haben, nicht dieses, was es eben gegen Düsseldorf nicht war. Gegen Düsseldorf gab es dann so Szenen, ich weiß nicht, Thorsten, ob du dich erinnerst, wo Mustafa dann einmal Jemfee und einmal Andruzzos, glaube ich, ins Gesicht gebracht hat. Das war jetzt nahe an der Grenze zur Un-Sportlichkeit, wenn nicht vielleicht sogar drüber. Da hat man sich überhaupt nicht gewehrt und das hat der Trainer vorher gesagt, das möchte er nicht nochmal sehen, sondern da will er auch schon, dass die Mannschaft stärker in diesen Kampf geht, in diesen Abstiegskampf. Und das haben sie gegen Fürth richtig gut angenommen und was dann halt noch umso überraschender war, war, dass man das eben geschafft hat unter einer extrem personell angespannten Situation. Also man hatte mit Dave Knase, der sich so zum Kopf der Mannschaft in der Rückrunde entwickelt hat, als zentralen Mittelfeldspieler einen Spieler mit der zehnten gelben Karte gesperrt gehabt. Mika Cuisens hat in Wiesbaden eine Riesendummheit begangen, nämlich hat erst wegen Zeitspiels eine gelbe Karte kassiert und hat danach dem Schiedsrichter applaudiert und es mögen Schiedsrichter gar nicht gerne. Hat dann also gelb-rot gesehen, also sprich, es waren zwei absolute Stammspieler und Schützen dieser Mannschaft gesperrt. Der Kapitän Timo Behrmann, der in Wiesbaden wieder Startelf hätte spielen sollen, nach einer langen Verletzungshistorie, ist schon in Wiesbaden krankheitsbedingt ausgefallen, konnte die ganze Woche lang nicht trainieren, stand mit Schniefnase am Freitag beim Abschlusstraining und hat seinen Kollegen zugeschaut. Dazu noch zwei weitere Spieler, ja, wie jetzt er mit Rorik und Verhuck eher unter Ergänzungsspieler oder Verhuck hat eben fast keine Rolle mehr gespielt zuletzt, aber die auch noch zumindest nicht mal im Kader stehen konnten. Und dann hatte man noch jetzt einen Ausfall mit Lukas Kunze, auch eher Stammspieler im Mittelfeld plus Erik Engelhardt mit Magen-Darm letzte Woche zwei Tage raus und Uma Diakite auch mit Erkältung und Grippesymptomen die ganze Woche im Bett. Also das war quasi eine ganz angespannte Situation, die es sehr heikel gemacht hat, weil der VfL auch zusätzlich noch überlegt hat, sein System umzustellen. Man muss mal wissen, der VfL hat fast überwiegend in einer Viererkette agiert, also im 4-3-3, und hat aber jetzt gegen Fürth auch, weil eben diese beiden Spieler aus der Stammformation mit Gnase und Cuisance fehlten und sich Košinat nochmal die Fürth angeguckt hatten, wollten sie also auf eine 5er-3er-5er-Kette in der Abwehr umstellen. Nur wenn eben von vier Innenverteidigern zwei angeschlagen sind, dann weiß man, dass das nicht funktioniert. Wenn der, der ursprünglich vielleicht noch eine Alternative gewesen wäre, nämlich Maxi Thalhammer, dann eben Dave Gnase im Mittelfeld ersetzt, dann geht das nicht. Deswegen war das alles ein bisschen auf der Kippe gestanden. Košinat hat aber alles auf eine Karte gesetzt, die ja KT und Engelhardt konnten spielen. Das war so mit der Schlüssel, dass diese Umstellung so wahnsinnig gut funktioniert hat. Die kann dem VfL noch mal eine zusätzliche Option geben im Abstiegskampf, weil er eben ein bisschen schwieriger auszurechnen sein wird. Die Mannschaft hat jetzt auch das Vertrauen zu dem Trainer, der sagt, wir stellen um und ich coache euch dadurch. Ich weiß, was ihr jetzt gegen diesen Gegner braucht und ich weiß, dass ihr das schafft. Ich glaube, dass das eine ganz wichtige Faktor sein kann, jetzt auch gegen so Mannschaften wie Kiel unter anderem, dass man da auch ein bisschen flexibler sein wird und weniger auszurechnen.
Und es ging ja auch sehr erfolgreich los. Dafür, dass Uwe Koschin gesagt hat, stellt euch mal drauf ein, dass ihr irgendwie Seife für die Augen mitnehmen müsst, finde ich Tor in der dritten Minute und Tor in der 21. Minute jetzt nicht so schlecht. Und wenn man gleichzeitig weiß, dass die Defensive ja aktuell auch gut steht. Jetzt blicke ich aufs Restprogramm von Osnabrück und dann sehe ich eben, du hast es gerade schon angesprochen, jetzt ein Auswärtsspiel bei Kiel. Auch da drückt euch, also Thorsten ist heute wirklich derjenige, der allen Gästen fest dir die Daumen drückt. Es tut mir leid, dass ich nicht mit dem HSV oder Kiel spielen kann. Also das wird natürlich aber dennoch eine Aufgabe, trotz des gedrückten Daumens von Thorsten. Aber dann haben wir Heimspiel gegen Eintracht Braunschweig, die sind aktuell 6 Punkte weg. Das Auswärtsspiel Magdeburg, was wir vorhin schon angesprochen haben. Heimspiel gegen Schalke 04, die sind aktuell 8 Punkte weg. Aber wir haben schon darüber gesprochen, Schalke spielt ein bisschen wie ein Absteiger. Zumindest hängen sie da unten drin. Dann auswärts bei St. Pauli, die könnten dann schon durch sein, ist der vorletzte Spieltag und dann Heimspiel gegen Hertha BSC. Es ist natürlich von allen Teams, die da unten drin stehen, die größte Aufgabe für Osnabrück, da irgendwie noch Richtung Relegationsplatz zu hüpfen. Wenn man aber gleichzeitig sieht, dass zwischen Rang 12 und Rang 17 gerade nur 3 Punkte liegen, dann wissen wir, dass da eigentlich auch alle nervös sind. Und da hat man es ja schon häufiger erlebt, dass manche auch übereinander stäufern. Was rechnest du dem VfL noch aus?
Also, ich habe heute nochmal mit Uwe Kuschin gesprochen heute Morgen. Wir haben so ein Video- Interview immer nach dem Spieltag. Und da habe ich ihn nochmal gefragt, weil er gestern in der PK gesagt hat, die Chance nach dem Sieg gestern gegen Fürth ist jetzt um 1% auf den Klassenerhalt nochmal größer geworden als vorher. Ich habe ihn gefragt, ob er nochmal nachgerechnet hat. Hat er? Er bleibt dabei. Und ich glaube auch, dass es im Moment wichtig ist, sich nicht zu sehr darauf nochmal zu fokussieren und zu gucken. Weil, wie du schon sagst, da werden noch einige nervös werden. Da muss man jetzt einfach schauen. Gegen Kiel wird es maximal schwer, würde Daniel Tunz sagen.
Muss man die etwa niederringen?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich glaube, die Hoffnung flackert noch und das ist eigentlich auch das Wichtigste, dass man selbst, wenn es am Ende nicht reicht, weil das muss man vielleicht auch noch hinzufügen, ja, sind jetzt sechs Punkte auf dem Relegationsplatz und sieben wären es auf dem Nicht-Abschiebsplatz, aber da ist ja noch dieses unglaublich schlechte Torverhältnis dabei. Also, da muss man auch immer noch einen dazu draufrechnen. Trotzdem, solange da irgendwie noch was drin ist, wird die Mannschaft da, glaube ich, alles geben und das ist auch etwas, jeder, der schon mal Abstiegskampf mitgemacht hat, der weiß, dass es irgendwann so einen Punkt gibt, da kippt es oft und da fängt es dann in der Mannschaft auch an, dass jeder mit dem Finger auf dem anderen zeigt und das ist halt beim VfL nicht passiert und vor allem nicht passiert nach dem 0-4 gegen Düsseldorf, wo man so etwas vielleicht auch hätte erwarten können, dass so ein Klackdruck eintritt. Und im Gegenteil, man ist zurückgekommen aus dieser Länderspielpause und hat sich jetzt wieder so präsentiert. Also die haben gezeigt, dass sie kämpfen können. Die wissen seit letztem Jahr, 90 plus 6, ist es nicht aus, bevor es nicht aus ist. Und ja, deswegen, ich glaube jetzt eigentlich die Rechenspiele und wer wie was und ob St. Pauli dann schon durch ist oder wie es da aussieht, da braucht man gar nicht anfangen. Ich glaube, die werden bis zum Schluss alles geben und selbst, wenn es am Ende nicht reicht, wird man in Osnabrück jetzt nach dieser Rückrunde auch sehen, dass diese Mannschaft eben sich dagegen gestemmt hat und alles gegeben hat und auch so was dann anerkennen.
Ich finde es ganz interessant zu sehen. Es gibt so verschiedene Gruppen an Vereinen unten im Abstiegskampf. Es gibt Teams wie Osnabrück und Braunschweig, die so von vornherein eigentlich reingegangen sind und gesagt haben, ja, das wird schwer. Und so war dann auch die Hinrunde. Dann gibt es die Aufsteiger, bei denen es euphorisch ganz gut lief – Elversberg, Wien, Wiesbaden – die jetzt hinten raus, wie es häufig bei Aufsteigern ist, aber so langsam die Abstiegsplätze wieder näher kommen sehen und so ein bisschen gerade nicht schaffen, den Schalter umzulegen. Und dann hast du die Vereine, die ganz andere Ideen hatten, wie Lautern oder Schalke, die auch vielleicht eine andere Qualität haben, die es aber einfach nicht schaffen, da unten rauszukommen. Ich weiß noch nicht, wo ich Magdeburg hinpacke, das muss Thomas mir sagen, aber ich finde das ganz interessant zu sehen. Ich mache gerade Schubladen auf, aber habe ich wen vergessen da unten? Die sehe ich dann auch in der Gruppe, Osnabrück, Braunschweig, die wussten, glaube ich, auch von Anfang an, das wird schwer dieses Jahr.
Ja, also ich glaube, hier war auch, also ich kenne hier wenig Leute, die in meinem Umfeld, die vor der Saison auch gesagt haben, es kann für den FC Magdeburg nur um den Klassenerhalt gehen, alles andere ist vermessen. Und auch wenn wir einen guten Saisonstart hatten, also für mich war das immer alles Bonus, das waren mal alles Punkte, wo ich gesagt habe, jeder Punkt, den wir da geholt haben, ist gut im Abstiegskampf, mehr nicht. Und ja, hat sich ja leider Gottes auch bestätigt, dass es dann doch brutaler Abstiegskampf am Ende noch wird für uns. Mal gucken, wie das dann am Ende ausgeht.
Ja, und da ist eben wirklich Resilienz ein wichtiges Thema. Und das muss ich schon auch sagen. Also, wenn ich jetzt überlege, wann hatte ich eigentlich bei Osnabrück, also wann hatte ich die abgeschrieben, dann war das für mich ehrlicherweise, als man nach 2 zu 1 Führung auf dem Betzenberg noch in der 92 Minuten mit 2 zu 3 verliert. Da dachte ich mir, okay, gut, wenn dir sowas passiert, dann hilft auch dieses kurze Ausbaubäume nicht. Aber jetzt sehen wir ja, naja, wer weiß, vielleicht geht da noch was. Wollen wir vielleicht zum Abschluss ein Power-Ranking machen, dieser Teams, die da unten drinnen stehen? Das ist natürlich höchst subjektiv und so weiter, aber das würde mich mal interessieren. Ich würde vorschlagen, wir machen den Cut bei Magdeburg, denn Elversberg 36 Punkte, es sind zwar nur 6 Punkte zu Braunschweig, aber da müssen ja so viele Teams sich dran vorbeischieben. Elversberg, ihr seid durch, vielleicht habe ich jetzt gejinkst, bitte schreibt mir keine E-Mails, sollte es so sein. Aber Magdeburg, Schalke, Wiesbaden, Rostock, Braunschweig, Lautern und Osnabrück. Thomas, du darfst anfangen. Wen davon würdest du aktuell am stärksten sehen?
Am stärksten von denen? Tatsächlich Braunschweig.
Thorsten nickt, aber Susanne ist irritiert.
Ich habe einen schlechten Eindruck von Osnabrück natürlich aus dem direkten Duell, aber Braunschweig fand ich jetzt schon stärker.
Ich hoffe, dass nach dem 20.04. das nach Osnabrück schwenkt.
Okay, ihr habt das direkte Duell. Das wird wirklich sehr, sehr interessant.
Ich glaube, dass das wäre. Ich glaube, also Braunschweig ist ja, aber das ist 20.04.
Okay, aber das heißt, du hast damit indirekt gesagt, Susanne, selbst wenn wir jetzt mal Braunschweig in unserem Power-Ranking auf einsetzen, dann wäre Osnabrück für dich die 2 aktuell.
Bei Schalke konntest du immer drauf achten, ob sie auswärts oder zu Hause spielen. Das ist einfach so.
Aber würdet ihr dann Schalke – also ist natürlich zu Hause besser für alle diejenigen, die sich das gefragt haben – Heimtabelle Rang 7, Auswärtstabelle Rang 18? Das ist wirklich verrückt. Ich wusste, dass Heim gut war, aber ich wusste nicht, wie schlecht auswärts war. Aber wo würdet ihr Schalke hinpacken? Ich meine, wir müssen jetzt kein genaues Ranking machen. Aber Braunschweig gerade eine gute Phase, Osnabrück eine gute Phase. Wo wir die genau hinpacken, ist dann letztlich egal. Aber was machen wir dann Thomas mit Schalke 04?
Also ich habe letzte Saison, als ja Bielefeld in einer ähnlichen Situation war, habe ich eigentlich, bis sie dann abgestiegen sind, eigentlich immer gesagt, bei denen, die haben zu viel Qualität, die bleiben drin. Das Gleiche habe ich von Schalke auch gesagt. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, ob das ein schlechtes Oben für Schalke ist, weil ich das bei Bielefeld auch getan habe. Also es ist schon brutal, wenn man sieht, dass eine Mannschaft, die ja eigentlich qualitativ schon eigentlich mindestens ins Mittelfeld der 2. Liga gehört, dass die so gar nicht auf die Beine kommen. Und das ist tatsächlich – ich kenne jetzt das Schlussprogramm von Schalke, ich weiß nicht, wen die jetzt noch alles haben – aber ich denke, am Ende wird Schalke – ich denke, am Ende wird Schalke mit zwei blauen Augen davon kommen und auf Platz 14 oder 13 die Klasse haben.
Ja, das glaube ich auch. Die haben sich zuletzt zumindest in den Heimspielen doch sehr stabil präsentiert. Das ist auch so meine Sorge, weil wir eben noch Ende des Monats dahin müssen auf Schalke. Dann haben wir noch mal am Samstagabend auch so ein Flutlichtspiel und so. Das ist so die Atmosphäre, die will man da vielleicht dann nicht haben für die Heimmannschaft. Das ist so mit das Spiel, von dem ich den meisten Respekt habe. Da bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob wir da gewinnen werden. Und ansonsten glaube ich eben, dass die Heimspiele reichen. Diese Heimstärke ist jetzt vielleicht übertrieben, aber die Stabilität zu Hause, glaube ich, reicht für Schalke zusammen mit dem Kader für den Klassenerhalt.
Die nächsten zwei Spiele könnten da schon ganz wichtig werden. Heimspiel gegen Nürnberg, gegen die sieht man traditionell eigentlich immer ganz gut aus. Und dann bei Elversberg auswärts. Und Schalke braucht ja nicht mehr viele Punkte. Aber gut, wir haben schon andere Dinge erlebt. Was machen wir? Ja, wäre dann schon Rostock der Nächste im Power-Ranking. Müsste eigentlich fast sein, wenn man so nach aktueller Form geht. Haben natürlich auch noch einige Brocken vor sich. Also spielen Harter, Magdeburg, St. Pauli, KSC, Schalke, Paderborn. Also haben so eigentlich mit wehen Wiesbaden die stärksten Gegner jetzt noch als Nächste. Susanne, wie schaust du auf Rostock?
Ja, also ich glaube auch, die haben jetzt wirklich zuletzt eine ganz gute Serie hingelegt. Wenn ich das richtig erinnere, glaube ich nur Kiel verloren, oder? Aber dann, ja, sich wirklich ordentlich und gut präsentiert. Aber das Restprogramm, das ist schon happig. Also da ist, da kommt einiges auf Rostock zu und, ja, schwierig.
Und ähnlich ist es ehrlicherweise mit Wien – Wiesbaden. Düsseldorf natürlich, wissen wir ja, in der Wunde im Schmuckkästchen. Thorsten freut sich schon. Dann Lautern, Fürth, Kiel, Braunschweig, St. Pauli. St. Pauli immerhin am letzten Spieltag mit Lautern und Braunschweig auch noch zwei direkte Duelle, aber beide auswärts für Wien – Wiesbaden. Du hast ja, Thorsten, fast schon so ein bisschen angekündigt, die Aufsteiger, die rutschen ja manchmal hinten raus noch rein. Wenn ich mir das jetzt so angucke, könnte ich mir das ehrlich gesagt auch vorstellen.
Das ist meine These, dass Wien-Wiesbaden am Ende noch unten rein rutscht, vielleicht auf den Relegationsplatz oder sogar tiefer. Schlechtes Test, Rückrundenteam. Und also ich habe ein bisschen das Spiel jetzt in Rostock gesehen und so. Das läuft schon lange nicht mehr so rund wie es dann phasenweise in der Hinrunde, als sie uns auch geschlagen haben nach einer harten Pokalpartie in Unterhaching. Da mussten wir zwei Tage später, freitags abends zu Hause ran und haben 1-3 wirklich sehr kraftlos gegen Wien-Wiesbaden verloren. Die Form haben sie, was ich zuletzt gesehen habe, überhaupt nicht mehr. Und das meinte ich eben mit so den berühmten Schalter immer umlegen. Ob sie das noch mal schaffen, da bin ich mir gerade nicht sicher. Ich bin schon sehr zuversichtlich, was das Spiel nächste Woche allen Spaß beiseite betrifft, da wir sehr stabil im Moment sind. Ich sehe gerade wirklich keinen Grund, warum das in Wien-Wiesbaden nächste Woche schiefgehen sollte. Das ist dann eine weitere Niederlage. Sie haben jetzt eine ganze Reihe Niederlagen zuletzt gesammelt. Vor allem dieses Heimspiel gegen Osnabrück dürfte ihnen wehgetan haben. Dann haben sie vorher einmal unentschieden gegen Hannover zu Hause gespielt, aber dann auch gegen Paderborn verloren. Die Heimspiele liefen zuletzt gar nicht gut bei Wien-Wiesbaden. Es sind ja keine ballbesitzorientierte Mannschaft, die auch aus einer sehr kompakten Defensive kommt, was man natürlich auswärts eigentlich gut nutzen kann. Aber wir haben heute schon häufiger darüber gesprochen, dass die Gegner sich dann phasenweise eingestellt haben. Ich glaube, das ist bei Wien-Wiesbaden mittlerweile eben auch der Fall, dass man weiß, den läuft man nicht mehr ins offene Messer. Da muss man auch ein bisschen die Qualitätsfrage stellen, wenn man sich den Kader anguckt. Da ist nicht so viel Zweitliga-Erfahrung dabei und das ist ja auch nicht – also das kennt man auch aus der ersten Liga, dass in diesen letzten Spieltagen auch gerade so die Mannschaften, die sowas schon öfters mal mitgemacht haben, dass die sich da häufig stabiler präsentieren als Teams, für die es eigentlich rosarot lief die ganze Saison und die am Ende dann auf einmal noch ums Überleben kämpfen müssen. Also Wien-Wiesbaden ist für mich ein heißer Kandidat von den Teams, die noch unten reinrutschen, von denen man es vor ein paar Wochen vielleicht noch gar nicht gedacht hätte.
Das sind hervorragende Nachrichten für Lautern und Magdeburg. Das sind die 17 Teams, die wir jetzt noch nicht gerankt haben. Lautern in der Rückrundetabelle, 16. Magdeburg, 15. Thomas, ich komme nicht drüber hinweg, wie frustriert du vorhin warst, und gleichzeitig habe ich Hände ringend nach irgendwelchen Argumenten gesucht und habe keine gefunden. Nicht im Kader, nicht auf der Trainerposition, umfällt noch am ehesten. Also Magdeburg kann ja auch eine Wucht entwickeln. Anders gelagert als Osnabrück, aber ja auch durchaus ähnlich, also dass man ja eigentlich lange hinter der Mannschaft steht und auch heimstark ist mit einem besonderen Stadion und so weiter. Müssen wir trotzdem Magdeburg und Lautern hier so ans Ende dieser Liste packen. Heißt ja nicht, dass man dann auch absteigt, weil vielleicht…
Zurzeit bei fünf Spielen, zwei Punkten, 0 zu 11 Toren, kommt man da glaube ich nicht drum rum. Also zurzeit kann man das glaube ich, ohne da jetzt böse sein zu wollen, kann man das glaube ich so sehen. Also diese fünf Spiele, dieser Trend spricht jetzt nicht gerade für uns. Ich glaube nur Elbersberg war in dem Zeitraum schlechter und ging die Spielzeit auch nur 0-0 dann. Ich denke, ich habe nur mal den Spaß gemacht und habe heute Nachmittag mal auf Kicker.de diesen Tabellenrechner mal genutzt. Genau. Susanne tut mir leid, aber tatsächlich ist für mich dann Osnabrück dieses Schlüsselspiel gewesen. Also ich bin am Ende bei 37 Punkten rausgekommen mit einem Sieg gegen Osnabrück und der war nachher entscheidend, dass man dann am Ende die Klasse hält. Ich glaube tatsächlich, das wird für uns auch dann das Schlüsselheimspiel um diese Saison dann noch zu retten und deswegen hoffe ich einfach mal, dass Osnabrück bis dahin vielleicht aus eigener Sicht natürlich vielleicht keine Chancen mehr hat noch drin zu bleiben, dass man da eben so ein bisschen so eine Egalstimmung reinkommt. Also nicht, dass man da nicht mehr spielen will, sondern dass man eben sagt, okay, hat er keine positiven Auswirkungen mehr. Ansonsten, es gibt mir tatsächlich nur Hoffnung, diese drei Spiele, die wir noch haben, gegen direkte Konkurrenz. Ansonsten sieht es da bei mir zurzeit auch eher mauer aus, muss ich ganz ehrlich zugeben.
Und dann haben wir Lautern und Lautern kann Friedhelm Funkel absteigen. Ich war ja kein Fan der Verpflichtung, aber ich bin auch weit weg von der 2.
Liga.
Ich bin noch weiter weg von Kaisers Lautern, deswegen ist da meine Meinung wirklich unerheblich.
Ich habe vor drei Wochen mit Sebastian Zobel gesprochen aus der letzten Rasenfunk-Sendung ja auch hier. Er sagte mir da, dass ganz Lautern das wirklich total begrüßt. Dass das mit Gramozis wohl überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat. Ich meine, es ist ja wirklich schon der dritte Trainer diese Saison. Es war fast wie eine Erleichterung, dass dieser Wechsel noch mal stattgefunden hat. Das Feedback von ihm war, dass das sehr positiv gesehen wird. Mal Pokal beiseite. Haben sie ja auch bis auf die zwei Niederlagen zuletzt gegen den HSV und uns eigentlich auch deutlich stabiler agiert. Das HSV-Spiel war für mich so ein typisches Abstiegskandidatenspiel. Du bist nicht die schlechtere Mannschaft, aber du machst deine Dinge nicht. Irgendwann wird aus vielen Schulterklopfen – na ja, ihr wart ja ganz gut – heute war er wirklich nicht gut. Wenn ein Trainer das wirklich verhindern kann, wenn einer weiß, was dazu zu sagen ist und wie eine Mannschaft einzustellen ist, dann ist das Friedhelm Funkel. Bei allem, was man über ihn sagen kann. Das kann er und meistens hat er auch das richtige Gespür dafür. Das ist der Funkelbonus. Den würde ich tatsächlich Lautern am Ende geben und selbst wenn es die Relegation sein muss.
Also ich sehe es ähnlich. Ich finde auch, Lautern hat mit der Funkelverpflichtung vieles richtig gemacht. Wenn man mal auf die letzten Spiele guckt, muss man die Kölner auch ein bisschen dorfen lassen. Die haben in Rostock 3-0 gewonnen, die haben gegen Osnabrück 3-2 gewonnen, dann haben sie in Hannover 1-1 gespielt und jetzt haben sie gegen Düsseldorf und Hamburg, gegen zwei Aufstiegsaspiranten. Du hast es schon gesagt, gegen Düsseldorf, das war ja kein 1-3, finde ich am Ende. Das war ja vom Spielverlauf eigentlich maximal ein 1-2. Also das ist eine Höhe. War das dann auch mindestens ein Tor zu viel? Düsseldorf hat dann einfach brutale Qualität und das hat man eben gesehen. Und jetzt gegen Hamburg eigentlich genau das Gleiche. Und wenn man dann mal guckt auf das Restprogramm von Lautern, die haben zu Hause Wiesbaden, die haben zu Hause uns und die haben zu Hause Braunschweig. Und wer schon in Kaiserslautern war, der weiß, was dieses Stadion für eine Wucht entwickeln kann, wenn es da mal rund geht. Und ich glaube schon, dass die in diesen drei Spielen, ich hoffe natürlich nicht gegen uns, aber in den anderen beiden Spielen, gegen Wiesbaden und Braunschweig, ihre Punkte holen werden. Und deswegen denke ich auch, es wird am Ende Wiesbaden erwischen als 17. Und dann Relegation ist mir egal, so lange wir das nicht sind.
Und das ist doch ein Schlusswort und wir haben sogar maximal nochmal untergebracht. Das schmeckt mir ganz wunderbar. Wir werden es ja eh verfolgen und uns angucken, in aller Ruhe oder auch Emotionen, je nachdem, welchem Fanlager man da angehört. Ihr 4, ich, äh, nee, ihr 3, seht ihr, ich kann nicht mal mehr zählen. Es waren zu viele Sendungen zuletzt. Ist dieser vierte Gast gerade hier anwesend? Nein, nur in meinem Kopf. Es ist wie Temfunkel. Also, ihr 3, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Alle Verzögerungen, die wir jetzt hatten, zum Trotz. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Thomas Haufe vom Nurder FCM Podcast. Danke dir. Sehr gerne. Und danke an Jorsten Wiese von Gebrabbel Rot-Weiß. Danke, dass du wieder da warst. Und herzlichen Dank an Susanne Vetter unter anderem vom Brückengeflister. Danke dir, liebe Susanne. Ja, ihr wart auch das perfekte Beispiel dafür, warum es so schön ist, mit Podcast-Expertinnen und Experten zusammen zu spielen. Wie flüssig das war. Zwischendurch hätte ich rausgehen können. Da habt ihr das hier komplett alleine übernommen. Fand ich sehr, sehr gut. Lieben Dank auch euch, lieben Hörern und Hörern, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bitte unterstützt den Rasenfunk auf rasenfunk.de slash supporters club. Erfahrt ihr, wie das geht? Auf kiosk.rasenfunk.de könnt ihr noch Tassen und so weiter erwerben. Es sind die letzten ihrer Art. 30 Prozent Rabatt gibt's da drauf. Holt sie euch, bleibt gesund und bleibt uns gewogen. Bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut. Das war der Rasenfunk. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.